make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into the
challenge of the ghostwriters storyline
for the Avengers here's the thing Jason
Erin's run on the Avengers is really
really cool but the funny thing about
this is that Jason Erin's run has served
two purposes so far is to either kind of
go towards what it is that model wants
to do in the MCU or to play cleanup duty
the idea was with blade coming in that
was his on to kind of bring blade more
into the forefront because as we know
blade is gonna be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the other thing about
this is that with regards to this story
and the story of Robby Reyes this is
cleanup duty
and the reason why is because back in
2015 when Robby ray is you know the
whole all-new Ghost Rider concept came
along with issue number 7 he met Johnny
Blaze who of course was probably the
most popular version of Ghost Rider
outside of Danny ketch and then in turn
the question was asked well is he a
Ghost Rider or is he not a ghost rider
right because Robby Reyes was never
possessed by a spirit of vengeance he
was possessed by the spirit of his uncle
Eli Morrow who is basically a dick and
so because of that he initially didn't
have things like the penance stare and
stuff like that like the ability to look
into a person and make them feel all the
pain they'd ever caused over the course
of their lives now that changed by
Marvel legacy number one insofar as he
got he got that ability by that point in
time but the biggest struggle with Robby
ray is in terms of how he fits into the
Ghost Rider mythos up to this point has
been is he Ghost Rider or is he not a
ghost rider where does he stand on this
and so this basically clears all that up
which is a long time coming to be honest
but what it does is it basically picks
up with rowdy Reyes hanging out with his
younger brother Gabe now of course for
those guys who were unfamiliar with this
Gabe is really the only member of the
family that Robbie Reyes has left that's
really the only thing he has in the
world for the most part it's always been
one of these things where Robby looked
out for Reyes as best he could now him
engaging as a pretty nefarious actions
ultimately led to his demise which led
to the spirit of Eli Morrow offering the
possession to Robby Reyes which he
accepted and then him going forward as a
ghost rider but it's always kind of
hiding who he really is from Gabe and
then trying to basically be by his side
and tend to him as best he can the issue
with this is that in the middle of them
driving where Gabe is kind of hyped and
he's excited about the idea of like go
fast go fast you know because you are in
a charger I don't know why you would
drive slow but in the middle of all that
the thing just starts start hightailing
it right just starts Holland super fast
the difference here is that under normal
circumstances and where we had
previously seen the car was originally
possessed by Eli morrow which passed to
Robbie Reyes that's not the case anymore
right like Robbie Reyes is not hearing
the voice of
Eli Morrow he's hearing the voice of
somebody else instead and so all this
craziness kind of going down here all
these crazy things that are happening
basically all kind of comes to a halt
when the car stops and that's when
Robbie Reyes what it begins to panic and
the reason why is because his response
is okay I don't know what's going on
with this thing right so he goes to try
to trash the car and then once he gets
back to his home the cars already there
now the reality is that much like almost
all the other ghost riders that have
existed out there Robbie Reyes doesn't
want this where he doesn't want to be
part of this anymore but as we know what
the Ghost Rider mythos once you're
bonded you're bonded there's really no
getting out of it others it's really
just some you're kind of stuck with
forever and ever and ever there's really
no no getting out of this whole thing
but he desires to leave the idea of
ghost rider behind so we can just go
back to the life that he had before I
was really always kind of the struggle
of his character and so of course
because he's part of the Avengers he
ends up taking it to Avengers mansion
and this is kind of a cool thing here
when it comes to the idea of like the
Midnight Sun so I this this whole you
know sort of supernatural esque
situation here well it is part of Marvel
Comics technically it kind of felt like
it wasn't like kind of fell like it was
out there doing its own thing now of
course you had Johnny Blaze you had any
catch of course who were who were guests
Danny ketch who were parts of the
Midnight Sun for a while but it always
kind of felt like he was out doing his
own thing and so when you look at the
midnight sons for what they were and so
far as like that kind of dark mysterious
side of Marvel Comics and then you have
Robby Reyes showing up to like the
Avengers all of whom were aware of the
midnight stones all I kind of stuff it's
a cool little kind of tip of the hat
right a minute something you always knew
was going on but it's also kind of cool
to see like Black Panther like I'm well
aware of all this and blade having been
part of the Midnight Sun at one point
it's like yeah like I know how all this
stuff works basically and so the cool
thing about this is that while all this
is going on one of the things that Black
Panther does he says okay let's like tap
into this card or see what kind of
energies there basically you know ham it
up and then see what kind of energy we
can pull off of it but at the same time
I also need to call somebody in it so
when that happens the car starts to lose
its mind of course you know but when
bunkers are going crazy and blades like
shooting at it we're just got above what
anything Carol Danvers is punching it I
just want to take a second to basically
show the Avengers are currently beating
up a car I think that's something that
needs to be needs to be pointed out here
I should I should title this I should I
should make it at the title the Avengers
versus ghost riders car but nonetheless
the person meant that black panther
ended up calling in is Daimon Hellstrom
now this is something I want to talk
about here for a second when it comes to
Marvel Comics
you've got a whole bunch of different
hellish realms right the other realm
where like Satan resides and then you
have like Mephisto and then you have
hella and her whole realm of health but
they're basically what it referred to as
Hell Lords when it comes to Hell Lords
each one of these guys are super
powerful in their own dimensions but
more so than that because they are Cu or
dimensions the hell Lords can leave
their dimensions at any point in time
and they can go into the main Marvel
Universe the general consensus across
the board is that the longer a hell Ord
stays away from their dimension the
weaker they get bringing in somebody
like Daimon Hellstrom who's the son of
satan it's kind of a big gamble because
the longer he's here the weaker he's
going to be and even being out of his
own dimension he's weak but this is the
kind of person that they need and so far
as somebody who can basically tap into
the mystical side of things especially
when it comes to these realms that
involve like Ghost Rider different
characters like that
and so with Daimon Hellstrom charming
into this whole thing it's kind of okay
so what you guys basically need here is
an exorcism we're going to exorcise this
car and we're gonna figure out what's
going on the funny thing about this is
that once this edge dozen takes place
right like one statement hailstorm
basically goes through and starts trying
to like someone you know whatever spirit
is inside this car out of the car itself
which of course is not Eli Morrow
suddenly Robbie Reyes and the car are
teleported into the realm of hell and
they're met by the arrival of Johnny
Blaze and this is a cool thing here this
this is something that I absolutely
adore about this right because what goes
on with this particular scenario is that
when Robby Reyes is talking to Johnny
Blaze Johnny Blaze basically says like
it's the nature of us as ghost riders to
ride right like it's what we do now the
reality of ghost riders is to basically
punish the wicked that's really what
they're supposed to do but Johnny Blaze
kind of puts himself off as I need your
power in order to keep this realm in
check you're a Ghost Rider like you have
to be a Ghost Rider and that's kind of
the funny thing is because Ronnie Reyes
tries to reject it trying to say like I
don't want this like I don't I don't
want any of this stuff I don't want to
be a Ghost Rider I don't want to have
anything to do with this and the
response of Johnny Blaze is but like you
don't have a choice it's what you do so
either you can participate in this race
or I can go to your your your little
brother Gabe I can take his soul and I
can make him a Ghost Rider and he could
take your place right that's kind of how
it works if you were to try to get rid
of becoming a Ghost Rider
there's a heavy price to pay meaning
somebody that you care about will take
your place and because the only person
out there that that robbery's cares
about besides himself is Gabe that it
means he'd be sacrificing his little
brother to become a ghost writer now I
think it'd be kind of baller if Gabe
were like riding a
like a Hellfire wheelchair chasing
people down the most horrifying
experience but it would be due it'll be
amazing I would love to see that story
where game is like chasing people now
fire coming out of like his like a
flaming skull on a wheelchair just like
chasing people down it'd be pretty
awesome I get me it'd be pretty baller
but but nonetheless because of the fact
that his brothers spirit essentially his
his immortal soul is online then
ultimately Robbie Reyes engages in the
chase now this is where things start to
get crazy and the reason why is because
this spirit that's possessing this car
we know it's not eli morrow but we don't
know who it is whoever it is has the
power to basically seize control and to
resurrect a dead celestial and then
start using it for its own meets and
that's not something easily achievable
right like being able to harness the
power of a being of that astronomical
strength and then in turn control it
it's kind of wild right so like whoever
that person is whatever this being is is
insanely powerful not only that over the
course of this race essentially while
Johnny Blaze isn't really cheating he is
certainly being unfair now this is
something that is kind of heart and
parcel to Johnny Blaze but at the same
time isn't and the reason why I say that
is because Johnny Blaze becoming the
King of Hell took place during damnation
right the idea that dr. strange had
accidentally opened up a portal to Hell
which allowed the Fisto to invade Earth
and so because that because the throne
of hell was basically empty Johnny Blaze
seized it and so when Mephisto got back
to hell and basically tried to retake
his throne Johnny Blaze basically led an
army of like all these ghost riders from
across handi against Mephisto and then
ultimately cast him out and Johnny Blaze
has been in control ever since but
Johnny Blaze had done things like freed
those individuals who were basically
tricked into service of Mephisto or so
on and so forth but basically like you
know I'm yes I'm ruler of hell but I'm
also kind of a good guy he's not he's
not a total jerk like v stone was but
what you're seeing here with this
version of Johnny Blaze who's basically
doing things like like pulling out these
tricks and essentially like screwing
over RB Reyes from possibly winning and
and so on and so forth saying things
like I'll take your little brothers soul
and so on and so forth it seems very
uncharacteristic of blaze as we would
expect him to be and the result of that
really the the explanation that comes
out of that comes by way of all these
different ghost riders that blaze had
used at one point in time in his battle
against Mephisto who's still resided in
hell and their response is essentially
the realm of Hell is corrupted Johnny
Blaze and so as a result of that this is
basically a darker more screwed up
version of Johnny Blaze and he
effectively is
like the new ruler of health the other
half of this is that once everything
kind of pops off with this car and once
Daimon Hellstrom kind of cast his spells
in order to draw this being out but of
course you have this fiery force it
essentially comes out I'm gonna reveal
itself to be the cosmic Ghost Rider
so cosmic Ghost Rider is back now and
this is kind of a funny thing right you
know because cosmic Ghost Writer being
here this is all just kind of
interesting thing cosmic Ghost Rider
being here facing off against or against
she-hulk and and so on and so forth this
is what we call inconsistency because
you're talking about a guy who basically
possesses the power cosmic right like
not the entire power of Galactus but
certainly a good portion of given the
fact that his power was provided to him
by Galactus at a time when Thanos had
conquered everything you ended up having
a version of ghost rider who is imbued
with cosmic energy that needed to be
powerful enough to be able to take on
that future version of fantasy I don't
really understand how this guy could be
you know comparable to that future
version of fan OHS and then actually
fight alongside him only to turn around
and be just powerful enough to be able
to hold his own against she-hulk and
forth not really sure how that whole
thing plays out probably for the sake of
storytelling because then you get cool
moments where like Thor basically some
as his hammer through the head of cosmic
Ghost Rider and rifts cosmic goes Rider
head off and he's like my head is like a
greater man than you'll ever be and just
like blows hellfire in his face because
really cool moments these really cool
little segments and so on but it's just
kind of like this great big huge brawl
that goes on there but that's really
kind of how things are playing out of
the Malheur right you basically got
Johnny Blaze who's essentially like
screwing over Robbie ray is with with
all these crazy things once Robbie Ray's
car repairs itself and he catches up
with Johnny then Johnny in turn summons
this giant celestial that's basically
imbued with the spirit of Eli Morrow who
visually starts haunting and destroying
the car of Robbie Reyes and while that's
going on cosmic Ghost Rider is is just
like going toe-to-toe with all of the
Avengers it's cool to see but honestly I
mean if we're being honest with
ourselves cosmic ghost riders should be
able to lay waste to these guys and it
should not be difficult either right
like he should do it like and not even
by a little bit but ultimately as short
as this fight is they all really kind of
come to come to agreement about you know
because initially the feeling of cosmic
Ghost Rider is all the Avengers were
working for Johnny Blaze and the reason
why was because sudden you know cosmic
Ghost Rider was doing his thing and then
suddenly he was taken by Johnny Blaze
and thrown in the car of Ronnie Reyes
and he's been in it ever since and so as
result so that he believed that what the
Avengers were doing was trying to keep
him confined inside
we're cosmic Ghost Rider was trying to
find a way to get himself out and so
once everything kind of comes to a head
once the dust settles and they all
realize you're basically on the same
side then the question becomes if Robbie
Reyes is stuck in hell with Johnny Blaze
then how do they get him out now Daimon
Hellstrom could possibly get them there
but there's no guarantee instead cosmic
Ghost Rider basically says I'm the one
that can get you guys in there like I'm
the one they can get you guys in there
and get you guys out and in truth that
makes sense when you're talking about a
being who's astronomically powerful
because he possesses the power cosmic he
can enter in and go in and out of any
dimension that he so chooses as that's
kind of what goes down here the cosmic
Ghost Rider ends up bringing in all the
Avengers who are like like traveling on
this giant skiff more or less which is
pretty cool ultimately they all just
kind of end up taking on Johnny Blaze
now here's something that I want to
point out to you guys is the power
Johnny Blaze possesses and how its
augmented in the realm of health Johnny
Blaze and this is one of the things that
people have kind of tend to forget about
tried-and-true ghost riders someone like
Johnny Blaze who is a tried and true go
try to possess where the spirit of
vengeance is insanely powerful
you know if somebody like Johnny Blaze
walked upon Galactus and like use the
pen and stare on him it would turn
Galactus his world upside down and I
think he has I'm not gonna swear to that
but I believe he has but like Ghost
Rider is insanely powerful right like
he's me it's no small thing for a ghost
rider to face off against some of the
biggest heavy hitters like will breaker
Hulk and things like that right so he's
not a small guy when you take the power
of Ghost Rider and then you amplify it
based on the realm of health it becomes
even greater and that's why stories like
this are cool but at the same time it
doesn't quite seem to add up
because when you're taking somebody like
Johnny Blaze who is that powerful who
fashions his own hammer of Thor right
like he literally recreates Thor's
hammer and then uses it you would expect
him to just kind of trounce the entirety
of the Avengers maybe there's some
magical protection there but for the
most part these guys should all be
decimated now the great thing about
stories like this we kind of have to do
going into it it's just suspend
disbelief I mean after all we are
talking about comic books right so you
got to have to suspend that disbelief
and just roll with this story for what
it is which is what I do these days I
don't get too hung up anymore well
here's the thing if I was like 17 years
old when this story came out I would be
like this was ridiculous and I would
like rage on forms and all that kind of
stuff these days it's just like this is
amazing this is an awesome fight and I
like it it's kind of roll with it from
there but
still you know for the most part it all
really kind of comes down to Robbie
Reyes and this is where we're really
Jason Aaron kind of jumps into the
cleanup duty
where's coming okay so what's the deal
with Robbie Rhea's really now Robbie
Reyes essentially has all the powers of
the Ghost Rider he's got the penance
stare he's got all these abilities and
so on so forth he drives a charger which
is really really cool but the idea is
like where does he stand with all this
is he one of you a Ghost Rider does he
not want to be a Ghost Rider how does
all this work and what is up happening
here is Rowdy Reyes basically comes to
terms with the role he plays that if
he's a Ghost Rider then he's a Ghost
Rider well like that's just kind of the
way it is there's no real casting this
off he just kind of accepts that he's
just another member in a long legacy
here now this seems like a small thing
or it seems kind of like okay you know
didn't really seem like you need a whole
story about that you can do a one shot
to a degree you're probably right but
the reason why this matters is because
what it does is it goes forward with
Robbie Reyes just like being the Ghost
Rider Jason Aaron can basically put this
whole thing behind him everything that's
happened since the beginning of all new
Ghost Rider up until now he can kind of
put all that and say okay like we've
done this you know we can go ahead and
put this story away we can close this
chapter of the book now let's tell
stories with Robbie Reyes as part of the
Avengers it works it's a really really
smart maneuver it's a really good thing
to do what you see this happen all the
time when it comes to these kind of
ensemble books but I think it's great
for the character of Robbie because now
to get to see him kind of full-on go in
and go forward and do his own thing but
the other big takeaway from this is that
there was a point in the story when a
coy way of Wakanda had basically brought
an Thor and shield now of course all
that took place before everything popped
off with cosmic Ghost Rider and whatnot
but basically said hey look we were
going through this cave this cave was
basically discovered during the war of
realms and so on and so forth what we
found in this cave was this Iron Man
helmet which seems to be like a million
years old like this this super old Iron
Man helmet we don't know how it got
there we don't really know what's what's
going on with this whole thing and so
what you end up getting is this sort of
scenario where I a man has been
investigating this cave the entire time
hence the reason he hasn't been here and
so as he goes through there and as he's
been analyzing all these energy
signatures wedding is up doing is
wicking something up and inside this
this helmet of silly just says resonate
myth Fisto and then like suddenly Iron
Man's teleported away to 1 million years
in the past and basically that's where
he is at the moment
Iron Man is 1 million years in the past
which is cool because here's the
question I have here's the question I
want to know the comic that comes after
this is star brand but then you also get
the Ghost Rider from 1 million
years ago my question is what's our
man's involvement going to be in like
that Ghost Rider in the Avengers right
because we know he's not the Ghost Rider
we already have the story of that
character for the most part but I'm
curious to see like what that story is
going to be and how that story's gonna
play out I want to see Iron Man team up
with the Avengers from 1 million BC
that's gonna be really cool well that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the rod
4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]